Everyone. My name is Kunal. I work as
a manager here at. We are here at
navigate, and, you know, in sunny Florida here
with Rawkode. I think it's, great. I've been
watching your channel for a while now since
I was a student. It helped me quite
a lot. I like the cluster series. It's
pretty cool how you, you know, fix broken
clusters, more hands on. Most folks, they just
write, like, read the blog post and make
a video out of it. It's not that
original.
It does help a few people because some
people like learning from videos. Some people like
learning from blogs. Some people like learning from
documentation.
I like to learn by doing, and I
think clusters
is like spot on for that. And I
really like how you utilize some of the
tools in your
livestreams as well. Like, I see you do
a lot of stuff with, like, the use
cases of Teleport, for example. I saw some
of the streams on that. They say I've
learned quite a lot, and I'm very grateful
to find the YouTube channel. Yeah.